President Trump is working hard to bring  jobs and opportunity back to our shores  carrier Ford and most recently with his  dissent based stimulus plan  I love protesters I'm going to develop  my own protest what you thought were  just swiftly signed unpopular executive  actions are actually tools for reviving  the flagging protest economy bringing  prosperity back to marker manufacturers  poster board companies pink yarn  distributors ACLU accountant Starbucks  window repairman lyft drivers  immigration lawyers Emma Craddock  exploratory committees and more Trump  isn't causing protests  he's kicking off stimulus and uniting  the country pumping more than 2.4  quadrillion zillion dollars into the US  economy and saving all the jobs all of  them you're welcome America I'm going to  develop my own protest